the Federal Reserve has been under the
gun since the beginning of the year when
it became apparent that inflation was
not transitory not going down anytime
soon and if you recall back in the
pandemic the Fed was riding to the
Rescue by reducing interest rates
aggressively the same federal funds rate
the short-term rate that Banks charge
each other instead of going down like it
was during the pandemic to help the
economy grow the FED is raising rates in
an effort to slow the economy down to
make conditions tighter
possibly to get people to lose their
jobs and it sounds cruel but it's all in
an effort to keep inflation which I
should say to get inflation under
control because you had all of these
factors that conspired together during
the pandemic people had money from
stimulus people had money from the
paycheck Protection Program and then you
had the supply chain so you got all this
demand and then you had restricted
Supply so it didn't take a PhD in
economics to figure out that prices
would have to rise to compensate Jerome
Powell the Federal Reserve chairman
feels probably like this problem is a
little bit of his own doing so it's kind
of his own credibility on the line and
he wants to show that he's going to take
care of the problem that he kind of
helped to create
the Federal Reserve is actually doing
two things to slow down the economy one
of course is to raise interest rates but
the only interest rates they can control
directly are the short-term rates the
federal funds rate and those that are
pegged off of that but they're also
selling government bonds out of their
balance sheet the Federal Reserve during
the Great Recession and also during the
pandemic loaded up on government bonds
that was called QE quantitative easing
and you may have heard the term QT
doesn't mean you're a cutie is that
means quantitative tightening so they're
going to be doing the opposite they were
pumping 120 billion dollars per month
into the economy and now they're
draining that liquidity out of the
system not quite up to 120 billion per
month but they will get there so the
same water that made the bathtub fill up
is now going to drain it a lot of
economists feel that inflation will
decline on its own Accord that the FED
need not be so aggressive in raising the
federal funds rate and draining
liquidity from the system
but if you look at the totality of it it
seems that inflation over time is much
more of a threat to long-term economic
growth than a temporary campaign to hike
interest rates so people who don't want
to see interest rates go up
I guess they want to still live on easy
street because if they don't do this now
if inflation doesn't come down then we
could be paying 16 for a Coke
this is almost like a uh a cleanse of
some sort by getting inflation out of
the system we can get back to a real
economy and there's real dislocations
going on out there people can't afford
homes people can't afford cars wages
need to keep going up and so once you
get in that spiral it's kind of hard to
break hey everything costs more I need
more money and then
it just keeps on going and going and it
really got out of hand in the 1970s
that's why there was uh drastic measures
taken then and Jerome Powell he was part
of the problem by getting rates too low
and keeping them there for too long so
he's indicated he's not worried about uh
slowing the economy down and he says he
doesn't want to have a recession but if
this continues it's quite likely
foreign
[Music]